just a few years ago Apple started to
make killer products that outclassed the
rest of their competition making
everyone including myself excited about
the Golden Age of Apple just look at the
2018
iPad Pro the beginning of the golden age
where no other tablet could compete look
at the iPhone 10 they completely
redefined the smartphone and everybody
followed them look at the airpods pro
the best fully wireless earbuds or we
can look at the Apple Watch series 4
redesign making it a much better Smart
Watch than it already was destroying all
the other smart watches or of course the
Apple silicon M1 family of chips
basically sparking the Golden Age of
Apple silicon dominating the PC World
especially for laptop
but now when you stop and look at
everything that's happened ever since
those Golden Age sparking products just
look at the iPad Pro it's barely
improved that much in the real world
since 2018. it almost feels stuck in
limbo due to constrained app support
just look at the M2 iPad Pro they
basically just swapped out the chip now
I know the iPhone 14 pro is awesome it's
refined the cameras are incredible the
display speakers they're all incredible
but it seems like we're getting the same
phone over and over again just slightly
refined each time it feels stuck yes the
airpods Pro 2 are the best fully
wireless earbuds out there but in three
years the design didn't even change at
all it's just been refined and tuned up
a bit more than it already has the Apple
watch has honestly not changed that much
since the series 4 just larger displays
and slightly better sensors we're seeing
practically the same watch get sold over
and over and over again and even the S8
chip is literally a rebranded S7 chip
which was already a rebranded S6 chip it
took the Apple watch Ultra to finally
give us something new and fresh and wow
am I amazed by that watch Apple did a
killer job on it and I Gotta Give Them
props for that and then we get over to
the Apple silicon transition taking the
World by storm basically dominating the
laptop space but now things are taking a
turn for the worst the M2 Chip ended up
being an overclocked and refined M1 and
things aren't looking so good for the M2
Pro and M2 Max is I'm gonna get into in
just a second but my point with all of
this is that just when it seemed like
apple was entering this golden age where
it dumb dominates multiple markets and
product segments everything took a weird
pause or slow down and now they seem to
be beginning to lag behind the
competition again and that makes me so
disappointed as an Apple fan and to be
completely honest it's mostly Apple's
fault for a couple of different reasons
combined with a pandemic that threw
everything into chaos and now Apple has
to begin to answer for their mistakes
which is going to cost them and
eventually it's gonna cost us the
consumers so let's get this story going
for many years Apple went all in on a
couple of different Supply chains namely
Taiwan and China until recently almost
all of their iPhones were made in China
specifically from a massive factory
named Foxconn on top of that almost all
of their Flagship high-end ships like
the a15 the a16 and their iPhones to
their M1 Apple silicon chip tips come
directly from a company in Taiwan named
tsmc the world's largest chip
manufacturer even though the warning
signs were in place for many years and
they continue to get worse during the
U.S and China trade War Apple continued
to rely on China while only investing
small amounts of resources into other
areas like India or maybe Vietnam and
even though the issues between China and
Taiwan have been persisting for a few
years now with China threatening to
invade Taiwan Apple has only now begun
to announce that they're going to be
sourcing their chips from other sources
including U.S factories in Arizona so
let's start this off with the China
ordeal that's going on right now that's
going to cause Apple a lot of short-term
and long-term pain ever since the
original pandemic lockdowns of 2020
Apple has been getting screwed by their
Chinese supply chain with products like
the 14-inch MacBook Pro being delayed by
over a year because of it as well as
them losing out on sales on products
that use Legacy chip nodes that were in
short supply and now they're getting
absolutely screwed by the China supply
chain again because of the massive
protests and riots going on which you
can see in this video that I'm just
gonna let play as I speak the reason for
the protest is because of the zero
coveted policy over in China which led
to the malnourishment and mistreatment
of the citizens there the people are
basically slaves to the Foxconn Factory
because they work eat and sleep there
did you know that apparently an
internship at the Foxconn iPhone Factory
is a requirement to graduate the local
high schools in the area yes those kids
cannot graduate until they work at the
iPhone Factory and why is that that well
because Foxconn is being pressured by
Apple to increase production as much as
possible for the latest iPhone release
season so Foxconn will go to any length
to make sure it gets the job done
because if they do they're gonna get
paid by Apple and apparently Apple could
care less how they get it done because
apple is pressured by the stock
shareholders and making sure their
earnings look as strong as possible and
it's disgusting that Apple talks about
caring for the environment and recycling
while allowing this sort of mistreatment
of Chinese citizens to go on for so long
during the protests the Chinese workers
at the iPhone factories were offered
massive bonuses to stay but many still
left because it simply wasn't worth
losing your life for and that's why if
you order an iPhone 14 pro right now
you're not gonna get it until after
Christmas so I truly hope that these
protests in China will help create some
positive change in terms of how the
workers are treated but the Dilemma for
apple is that every positive change for
the Chinese iPhone worker ultimately
means that Apple makes less money on the
bottom line so because of the protests I
believe Apple will finally get the
scrutiny and pressure it deserves on
this topic which might lead to Apple
having to raise product prices to
account for that making it worse for
everybody including us the consumer for
example Apple already increased the
price of the budget iPad 10 much more
than anyone was expecting even myself I
personally predicted it would start at
399 and many people disagreed saying
that it was too much but Apple came out
with a 449 dollar price tag which is
honestly too expensive for what you get
now I'm happy about the iPhone 14 pro
still being a thousand dollars but if
Apple gets pressure over their China
issues I'm afraid that's not going to
last long now moving over to the Taiwan
issue Apple now has more pressure than
ever to diversify away from Taiwan in
terms of how they Source their chips so
just the other morning we got an
announcement that tsmc is opening up an
even more advanced four nanometer chip
factory in Arizona which will open up in
2024. now the issue with that is that
we're expecting three nanometer chips
100 guaranteed by the end of 2023 so
when that factory opens up in 2024 it
won't even be making Flagship chips for
the iPhones and Macs and if you didn't
already know three nanometer was
originally planned by tsmc to launch in
the fall of 2020 with the a16 ship being
built on three nanometer Tech but due to
all of this supply chain issues it was
delayed so it no longer made that
deadline and because of that the M2
check for the Mac remained on the same
five nanometer node basically being a
stop Gap chip with the real M2 based on
three nanometer being delayed until the
M3 chip in late 2023 next year and now
we're getting leaked performance
benchmarks of the M2 Pro and M2 Max
chips with pretty poor performance
compared to expectations just look at
how Intel's chips destroy the M2 Max and
both single core and multi-core this
points to the M2 Pro and mass shifts
being based on the same five nanometer
again which would be the worst case
scenario because they were already
delayed until this spring of 2023 so we
all assumed they'd be built on three
nanometer because of that delay but what
if Apple both delayed and kept the chips
on the same process node or maybe even
giving it the four nanometer process
which is essentially just refined five
nanometer in terms of technology and it
also doesn't help that tsmc greatly
increased the prices and even forced
Apple to pay those higher prices for
their silicon nodes because of all of
the supply chain and inflationary issues
so it seems like all of these supply
chain issues are causing Apple to give
us underwhelming products especially on
the Apple silicon side and it's all due
to these supply chain issues that
bloomed from the pandemic and got
exponentially worse because of Apple's
hardcore Reliance on Taiwan and China
and now on the other hand from Apple's
perspective it could make sense to give
us underwhelming products like the M2
iPad Pro which essentially only got a
chip swap and not much else the reason
for that is that Apple probably knows
that a deep recession is here and it
doesn't make sense to put your best
products out there during a time when
people aren't willing to pay more for
the best products it probably just makes
sense to give us the same old thing
again just refined a bit more just for
Apple to continue their sales and
marketing throughout the recessionary
period until they can get a more Clear
Vision of how the next couple of years
will pan out but keep in mind that when
they eventually do end up giving us
these killer products when things settle
down the prices will also likely go up
so the value aspect won't be as sweet as
it currently is so with that said for
the time being it seems like the Golden
Age of Apple is over and it's not going
to be easy for Apple to fix this unless
all of the China protest news gets
covered up and silenced so they can keep
going on with their current ways and
especially if China backs down on their
threats to invade Taiwan on that'll make
it a lot easier for Apple but if these
issues keep escalating more and more and
more then things are going to be looking
pretty bad for Apple because they're
gonna have to change and it's going to
make it worse for their bottom line so
with that said if you completely
disagree with anything that I said go
ahead and comment down below but if you
enjoyed this perspective then click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign